Greetings disperse beings of planet earth.
Welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is the extremely charming, charismatic
and extroverted Brogan Graham, who in addition
to being kind of a style icon,
a guy with his own gravitational field,
and also an exceptional host
during my April visit to Minneapolis,
which was all his idea by the way,
Brogan is also the co-founder of November Project,
which is a free, open, urban outdoor space,
open to the public, gung-ho, group led, script flipping,
global fitness movement thing,
basically a collective of communities
that today counts over 250,000 lifetime members
in 52 cities, in nine countries all over the world.
This conversation covers a lot of ground,
it's about many things, dating, friendship,
building community, getting outside your comfort zone,
not just in the context of fitness,
but in all aspects of life.
If there is a general theme to this one,
it's about the importance of always seeking friendship,
cultivating inclusivity and calling people in
rather than calling them out.
As I'm fond of saying prophets walk among us,
Brogan is definitely one of them.
I love this dude, I dig this conversation
so, pretty please, hit that subscribe button,
we just eclipsed half a million subscribers
so, thank you all for that,
next stop, 1 million
and enjoy this episode of my bromance
with Brogan Graham.
Brogan Graham.
Rich Roll, the Rich Roll podcast.
We are in Minneapolis,
what are we doing here?
I think I convinced you to come visit.
You did.
And I just pulled out all the stops
and I am shocked that you're here.
Yeah, solely by dent of your efforts,
but I'm super excited to be here man.
I actually can't believe that you're here.
You didn't think it would happen.
Well, I kept aiding you to make it sound like
I was going to pull the plug at the last minute.
On to the weather, it snowed this morning.
That's all right.
I know, but after all those years in Southern California,
like weather is a thing.
Meaning like...
It is the end of April,
you would think the sun might peak out a little bit
but maybe not so much.
And I went to a workout this morning and I was
looking for other folks to like talk,
there's snow on the ground,
I was like are we not talking about this?
And it was very uncool.
Like I was exposing myself as a recent...
You lived here long enough.
there should be
A year and a half.
Something that isn't worthy of being all that.
Yeah, but I stopped asking, I was like, oh God,
this is very uncool.
It's gotta be sort of April,
well, March has gotta be terrible
'cause that's when you think, oh, it's March,
it's spring now, and again it's starting shifting.
And then you get slammed.
You get one weekend and it's like 60 or 70 degrees
and Minnesotans are wearing shorts and like we're thrilled.
And then it's like, oh, I think it's summer,
I think we're just in.
And then it's...
But you're like the guy who's wearing shorts
year round anyway.
Some of that.
Pull the mic up a little bit closer to you.
Like that?
Now that your voice isn't booming.
Why?
Well, the microphone thing,
I also go like really loud, go hard into it.
That's the way you live your life.
I'm pumped to be on.
It's been four years.
It's been four years?
Yeah and then that's honestly weird,
that's the only time I've actually met you.
No, that's not true.
Oh, because I went to that November Project...
I dragged you to West LA.
I'm still recovering from that.
West LA.
That was at least three years ago.
I think that was two years later.
Two years later?
So, we're internet friends.
We are and then we took a stab
at doing a little remote recording
that I was going to append to the top of a podcast
about being a dead
and that was one year ago.
Let's talk about that for a second.
You called me, I think in June or July or something?
It must've been June.
And you were like, yeah, I want to add,
I'm going to start doing these shorter clips
to add to other podcasts that were upcoming.
And I was hesitant, I was like, Rich man,
it's a pretty intense time here,
are we doing this?
And you're like, yeah
and we recorded it and then it was just like...
And then Minneapolis exploded.
Minneapolis exploded.
And I was like
there's no way.
And then you call me back
and you're like, sorry.
We can't, sorry.
Sorry.
Yeah.
So, that's a good lead in to addressing the elephant
in the room.
I definitely want to open this by saying out loud
that I'm not sure anybody needs to hear
from two white cisgender, upwardly mobile,
suburban dwelling dads.
Who are already taking up space.
Right.
Already taking up space, white space.
To bro out on a curfew imposed Minneapolis
in the middle of a COVID spike, the Dwayne Wright shooting
and the show in trial.
Does anybody need to hear our opinions on racial justice,
Black Lives Matter or civil rights, I mean, it's ridiculous.
But we're here and it's rolling
and I think that there's some value in conversation
and you talk about it all the time.
It's like I have grown to really appreciate you as a host
and as someone who brings not only people together,
but like the best out of those people
and to sit and have a conversation
and like we talked about it on the way over here,
it's like, or the last couple of days leading up to this,
it's like, there's also a lot of life that's going on here
in Minneapolis that applies elsewhere.
Opinions and things that we're kind of
trying to sort through as middle-aged white dudes.
I think that there's a ton of value.
So, to you and your crew, thank you for coming here.
I don't know that I would have come here
just to interview you though,
that's not...
Let's put that up.
You put in motion this opportunity to sit down
with mayor Jacob Fry,
that was kind of the instigating impulse.
Of course, coming here then,
it became our responsibility to find community leaders
of color, to talk to,
it wouldn't have been great to just interview the mayor
and not get a different point of view or a perspective
of somebody who is really immersed in the movement
and the community.
So, we're doing that as well.
We're recording this one first though,
so, I don't have the experience of having sat down
with those folks yet, we will release this afterwards.
And I also have this feeling like the recording
from a year ago, that didn't ever see the light of day,
that there's a chance that this
might not see the light of day.
So, if this gets banked...
No, this is going to go up.
But what's interesting about that experience,
I think reflecting back on that,
I recognize my level of disengagement
and ignorance or naivete, I guess I should say
around exactly what was happening here
and the import of it nationally and internationally,
that it's become.
Yeah, I mean, I thought of that
'cause I remember having that conversation with you
where I was hesitant 'cause I...
Well, you were boots on the ground here.
So, you had a tactile connection.
We were living in uptown and we were about little less
than half a mile away from George Floyd (indistinct)
what is now George Floyd square.
And there's two things with that,
when you talk about that,
there's the piece that's about understanding
how outraged this city was, okay?
There's that piece.
But then there's also a piece about like large-scale crimes
and terrorism that happened way down the road.
Like I remember hearing about certain things growing up
and feeling like Oklahoma city is a million miles away.
That's hard to wrap my brain around,
and when the twin towers came down, I was living in Boston,
I felt a lot closer, but we weren't in New York City
and like the whole world was shaken by that,
but is it different to be closer
and so to have those conversations with you, it felt weird,
it was like, I don't know
that we were connecting on the same.
Yeah, we weren't because I didn't understand
what was actually happening.
And then fast forward,
I think not even a couple of weeks in all cities.
Yeah, it became a very different picture quickly
for everybody.
For sure, for sure.
And going back to how you kick this show off,
I was one of my highest council members, my mother, Ann,
I told you she's a huge fan
and I told her that you were coming
and she's like, oh great.
Like she thinks we're all just friends
from like her friend driveway playing basketball growing up,
like she pretends like we're...
Pleased together.
Oh, Rich is coming,
its like, he wasn't that big of a deal
but she said, oh I hope you guys don't end up
looking like idiots, she said that.
There's a very good chance
that's exactly what's going to happen.
So, she goes one way back (indistinct)
I'm glad he's engaged and,
I don't know how much of this you've done
where you go to, like where it is, this is like...
No, I mean, I've gone to cities and done podcasts
in cities, but they haven't been event driven.
So, this is unique and different in that regard.
And on some level, I think it's a reaction
to the world having been shut down the past year
and being unable to travel, which is something I love doing.
And we had a tour set up, we were going to do live events
in like six cities, so that didn't happen.
But on top of that, and most importantly,
just a recognition of the significance
of what's going on here,
the fact that the whole world is watching,
moment to moment, what's transpiring here.
It just felt precious and important
and the opportunity arose because of you
and I couldn't say no to that.
Yeah and I was stoked well, and I...
But I do want to get it right too,
so, I feel that responsibility.
But that's a white guy thing
and I'm not trying to teach anybody.
I'm not trying to teach anybody, but...
You've kind of done some training around this.
Right.
It's formal training.
We're not supposed to talk about the work.
Okay, that's part of the training too.
But do it and then like tell some piece,
I think that the idea of perfectionism,
the idea of getting it right,
the idea of like having a messy conversation perfectly
is like, well that's nearly impossible,
especially for white folks that haven't handled race
the same way and have lived a pretty easy life
here in the United States.
Like to think that we're going to step into an arena
and get it all right.
There will be missteps on this trip
and in these conversations and on my side
and one of the things that one of the equity advisors
for November Project told me today was acknowledge
at the top, acknowledge at the top of the show.
And you sort of did it, but I'll do it again for myself,
for both of us, like what if you were launching
into a conversation where you're going to make mistakes?
Not like if we have a mistake on these topics
and I don't even know which ones we'll cover,
but if we have one, then we'll no, no, no,
let's just assume we're going to make mistakes
'cause you and I are both new to this,
it's embarrassing, right?
But it's probably better to proceed,
going towards some mistakes, but in the right direction
than like let's freeze up until, yeah...
Well, you get all rigid,
because you must say the right thing
and then the conversation
really doesn't end up going anywhere
because you're coming from a place of fear.
And if there's one thing that I've kind of learned
or gleaned from conversations that I've had
over the last 12 months on this subject,
it's that, it's exactly what you said,
like you can't be afraid to have the conversations,
acknowledging you're not going to get it perfectly.
I think there is a trepidation with a lot of white people,
they want to talk about it but that fear prevents them
from even having the conversation
because they don't want to get it wrong,
they don't want to get castigated
for saying the wrong thing.
And so, those conversations never transpire.
Yep and then those out there that are like,
yeah, I want to, yeah, okay,
I'm going to do the reading
and I'm going to get it right
and I'm gonna figure it out.
And then I'm gonna engage and they engage,
and they engage and they get it wrong
and they get called out or called a racist
or critiqued and then...
And then the white fragility of...
Flares up.
Like I'm trying, why are you taking me down?
But it's not the responsibility of the black community
to give you a pat on the back and say, good job.
Right, and if we're living in this like an insular
like existence of white privilege,
that puts you in a place where you've practiced
your whole life not taking criticism
and so, it really doubly hurts, it's 10 times,
I'm not used to this,
It's like, well you should enter this,
enter the real world a little bit,
and look, it sounds as if I'm like coming
from a place of experience, I am
when it comes to messing up,
like when it comes to doing the wrong things
and proceeding as if I know the whole picture,
but it's the way I've looked at building community
and the way I looked at November Project
has been through the lens of who I am and running,
of who I am and it was in Boston
and kind of how I saw bringing a group together
and how to supercharge your group.
And so, I don't take credit or responsibility
for all of November Project,
but I think it was built by two white guys.
And I think there's another thing
that Somia and I spoke about today is like
for my white friends out there that look in November Project
and just say, that's fun, it's just fun,
it's not racist, it's a free community thing.
People should show up if they can
and if they can't, they can't, and it's for everyone.
And it's just good.
I would say it was comfortable for us and we chose locations
for us and we chose to bring people together
in the only way we knew how, and we did it
with our language and our social media and the group
is formed by two cisgendered white guys,
two rowers in Boston, like...
The Northeastern Colorado, like fancy school pedigree.
And when I'm having the beginning of this story
and I could tell it's not landing,
I say could two black men have,
could two shirtless black men
have gone into the Harvard stadium
and built a group of three, four or 500 people
that were screaming and waking up the neighborhood
with booming fuck yes
and like hugging it out and just having the best time.
And what would that look like?
Like how would that have looked?
And I'm not talking about Harvard University,
I'm not talking about Boston Police Department,
I'm not talking about the neighbors in the residing areas,
I'm talking about all of it.
And I think that kind of helps frame it as far
as like from the beginning, we were operating
with white privilege, is the Harvard stadium open
to training?
Well, it's open, so we go in
and we make it our home.
And that's a very privileged way of operating.
Yeah, that's a super interesting perspective on it.
I mean, that takes a lot of maturity
to kind of own that aspect of it, because it is easy
and on some level, you could make the argument correct
to just say, look, we put this thing together
and anybody can come, there's no closed doors to anybody,
but to step back and really objectively deconstruct that
from a systemic perspective to kind of own that,
I imagine that took some work to get to that place.
And then of course the question becomes,
where do you go from there, right?
Like, how do you, not to say that you did anything wrong
but acknowledging that you could do better,
like, what are the steps you put in place?
Because it is all about community,
community is the bed, bread and butter
of the whole November Project,
that's the ethos of it.
So, how do you broaden that aperture
to make it more welcoming to all comers?
I think even just laying out that context of what it is,
who it's for.
And I think community members and leaders,
people who have been once, people who are diehards
like if we can't see that access that we've had,
and if we can't see, one of my favorite stories
from the Boston days was like this police officer came
and told us never to come back to this hill again.
And I assured him we would exactly seven days from then
and I'm like talking to this guy with no shirt on,
just barely respectful but like kind of having fun
with the conversation.
And he said, if I'm going to write you a warning today
and if you come back,
it's going to be to a couple hundred dollars ticket.
Because it's too loud or?
Yeah, well, it says...
Yeah, so he said, neighbors have complained
and I said, I don't think that they have,
and he goes, well it's a sound ordinance violation
and I was like, well, I'm gonna work on that
and then he's like, well, just don't come back
and I said, I'll see you seven days from now.
And this defiant nature of how,
the coolness of being kind of just rad
and like laugh in the face of authority.
Like I need our community to see that
that's how we built this.
Like I need a community to look at that as white privilege.
And if you don't want to come along on that ride,
that's going to be hard.
Your question was how do you go about and change that?
And you can't change the origin story
but acknowledging that had that been a black dude
having that confrontation with a cop,
it would have been a very different outcome.
And I think I agree.
And I think the people that can watch the news
and see black and brown people being killed
for traffic violations and then play back that story
I just told you, we got to see that difference
and so, I'm really lucky to be a part
of this Tuesday night group
called White Men for Racial Justice.
And it's like 100 dudes, the jumping...
I thought you we're we're supposed to talk about that.
But I'm going to mention it, but then move on.
And the reason I brought it up
is because every Wednesday morning,
then I go to November Project.
And so, I'm kind of waking up fresh off
of this last conversation before I went to bed,
before I got back with the community in November Project.
And one of the conversations about this groundwater theory
and then like how racism is in everything.
And I think when people want to solve things quickly
and figure out how to make things right overnight,
you come to this barrier of frustration.
And I think that's the first reaction
of how are we going to fix this,
how are we gonna fix November Project?
Can November Project dismantle white supremacy
and you laugh, but it's like,
I think that dismantling white supremacy happens
in small spaces, times a million, right?
And so if we can make small changes
with the location that we host a workout,
what does it mean to choose something in Dallas
or in Orlando or in London that's "centrally located?"
What does that mean?
Centrally by whose definition, right?
Yeah.
I mean, social media is such a toxic place right now
but I saw some that that was really great
which is like this idea of there's a big difference,
the line was there's a big difference
between all are welcome
and this was built with you in mind.
And I just thought it was super powerful,
like we were guilt tripping half the city
if like you can get there, get there,
but we were really just talking to white folks
we are connected to.
Yeah, there seems to be this tension between
or this internal tension with white people on the one hand,
this desire to participate in the solution
but also a cautiousness like, is this really my place?
Is it appropriate for me to participate in this?
Or is that going to come across in the wrong way, frankly?
And I think that creates a lot of paralysis.
Participate in this meaning?
In the progressive movement towards change.
Yeah.
It's fun, it's funny you say that,
I always looked at friends of mine or co-leaders
who I would consider activists,
especially white folks that I saw wearing BLM clothing.
And I always thought that they'd done all the reading
and that they were in it
and they were like must've been experts
or they had voted the right way
and given their money there,
were a mentor and also knew all the policies
and they're really fighting the fight
every minute of every day and they've been at it for years
and this idea of starting somewhere,
like one of our leaders in Kansas city, Nicole,
I really admire her, she's always boots on the ground,
always having these conversations,
always challenging white folks in her life
and having conversations,
but she's always wearing BLM gear.
And I always looked at her and I admired her
and it was almost like she's on the varsity team.
I like she's an anti-racist,
but I kind of read a couple more books
like, I'm not there yet.
And I've had friends in my life recently just be like,
no, you have to start, if it's signaling with a yard sign,
if it's a hooded sweatshirt, if it's donating,
if it's the training that you're doing
with November Project co-leaders,
just continuing education but then you have to go out
and have these conversations.
You have to go out and participate
and build meaningful relationships.
And so anyway, I find the bummer of a challenge
is getting folks to take a step to start something
and it was so easy for me to talk about that
when I was talking about fitness, right?
And it was so easy for us to figure out diversity
and how to bring different kinds of athletes along, right?
Like that was a really an easy one for us to talk about,
but a lot of people, especially white people freeze up
when it comes to I don't know where to begin.
And...
What about the person who doesn't want to begin?
Like you must have people in your life
who really don't want to engage with this,
certainly not at the level
that you've been engaging with it.
Yeah, so, I'll give you my answer,
for me, I've always said,
and I said this to you back when we met years ago,
which is I give people a lot of chances
and how that shows up in these conversations
is that I'll meet someone where they are,
I'll have a whatever pace conversation you need to have,
I'll politely try and debunk and explain and understand
where your positioning is
and meet people, wherever they are on the road, right?
If someone says there is no problem,
if someone says race isn't a thing,
I think that's really a hard place to start, right?
But one of the six community agreements for November Project
is this idea of calling people in.
And it sounds so gentle and a little bit hippy
of like don't call people out Rich, that's too messy,
call them in, but there really is some truth to it,
which is like if you call someone out and say,
well, that sounds racist, I think you're racist,
like how much could you even repair that relationship,
conversation...
Ended any opportunity for moving the needle
and you've destroyed your relationship
with that person in the meantime.
And so to learn more, to ask more questions
and understand where they're coming from,
I mean, that process takes a long time, it takes patience.
And if someone were to say, I'm not here for that,
I'm cutting that person out of my life,
I also understand that for them.
But I recognize sometimes with white people in my life,
I can make change by saying, tell me more about that.
Is that really how you feel, have you thought that through
or is that just kind of the people around you
for most of your life?
Like where does this come from?
And I think tone is a tough thing, right?
'Cause we can come off pretty judgmental
with just the wrong kind of angle or the tone.
Yeah, tone is hard enough in person,
forget about it on social media 'cause it's gonna wear fast.
But it's so interesting that you,
we went into the whole November Project origin story,
the first time that we sat down
and people should listen to that podcast,
I love that conversation.
So, we don't need to retrace all of that
but it starts in Boston, you end up moving to San Diego
and continue to build November Project.
And then how many years ago did you move to Minneapolis,
three years ago?
So, we moved here July-August of 2019.
So, a year a half.
Yeah, and now with everything that's transpiring
in the city, making it literally ground zero
for the civil rights movement, right?
Provide you with a lens into a level of truth
that perhaps you wouldn't have been exposed to.
And in turn, that gives you a depth of experience
that you can inject into November Project
to really make it a leader in this kind of new evolution
of community fitness.
I would like to think so, I'd like...
It's like almost divine,
it was almost like meant to be, right?
Like it's weird.
It is weird that and to go back like so,
very happy in San Diego, we were married in the Hoya,
we moved there January 1st of 2015,
fell in love with the surf culture,
fell in love the people,
Goldie is my wife's sister, lives there in Pacific beach
and we had a little baby,
we're kind of living that renters life,
like kind of pretending
like we could live in nice neighborhoods
but he just didn't have like a long term plan.
What if we're gonna have a second kid?
I don't know how that's going to go.
What if we wanted to buy a house?
And so...
Meanwhile, like November Project's free,
I'm always like, how's this dude pay his bills?
How does this work?
Right, you want to get to that?
Yeah, sure, yeah.
So, I left my job, I was in marketing
for a couple of years.
I worked for the performance running team at New Balance
in I think 13 and 14, before that,
I had some other active lifestyle marketing jobs.
And we signed a partnership with the North Face,
which was strong for half a decade.
And that partnership fuels our leadership gatherings
in input-outdoor training gear on all of our leaders.
And it gave us the ability to quit our jobs
and not only work on November Project full-time
but also, build some of their community ideas
around training and then, so at the end of 18,
we were in conversations with Brooks,
running our contract was up with the North Face
and the Seattle based run company, the name and running.
And so, that quickly changed kind of the way we talked
about playing outside with all this winter gear
with the North Face to like no run happy,
be in the run, enjoy your run
and that relationship now is two years strong.
And so, the partnership piece keeps November Project
as far as the investment of keeping organization.
It's cool, it's cool that a brand can get on board
with that and they understand the value proposition
and because the community is so strong and not for nothing,
shout out to Dez Linden, Brooks Anthony.
Yesterday.
Up to 50K, world record, crushed it
by like seven minutes yesterday.
Dez went under three hours for 50 K
to do the new world record for 50 K of running
and a 50 K of running for those 31 miles,
I've done 50 K a couple of times,
it took me like a million hours,
and my fastest road marathon
is three minutes slower than Dez.
She held 547.
But Dez is, did you see any clips?
I mean were you (indistinct),
No, I mean, I was watching Josh's Twitter feed
and we fought, I mean, we were on route to the airport
and all of that, like trying to get here.
So, there was no live stream of it anyway,
it was just a Twitter thing,
but it was cool to see the level of Twitter involvement.
Like the whole internet was like all about...
running internet was like all about this.
And everybody jumped on board to celebrate this
which was really an event, it's a COVID event,
like they mapped out this course and just kind of did it.
It wasn't like a scheduled race or anything like that.
It was so awesome...
Everybody was watching it.
It was so awesome, we did our weekly Brooks call today,
and we were talking about Lauren and Brian and Boyan
and myself, the four of us are on a call every week.
And we were just talking kind of that,
the attitude of just kind of doing it,
it was like in some ways it was like real running,
like it's been a while since we've all...
There kind of a November Project flare to that, right?
We don't need all this other stuff, here's the road...
So cool and the finish line was like held up by Josh
and the person is like...
Shout out to Josh Cox.
San Diego Padres team manager.
Big Padres fan.
Yeah, and let's see, we have another partnership
with a an eyewear company in San Diego.
But Dez, has come through a handful of times,
I've run into Dez in San Diego
and Dez also lead one of our Leadership Only Runs
in Seattle when we brought everyone together in 2019,
we call it the Meeting of the Minds.
And so, I know that a lot of November Project,
especially the leaders were watching yesterday.
So, shout out Dez, you're amazing, again.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But I want to snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already
know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans and lagoons
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools
and support, very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience some version
of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say is
the Plant Power Meal Planner, our affordable,
all-in-one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.rich roll.com
and right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code, RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people
for just a dollar, 70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.rich roll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
It must be challenging for you,
we're switching gears a little bit here.
I mean, there's introverts, there's extroverts,
and then there's extreme extroverts.
I would put you on the far end of that spectrum,
of extreme extrovert, gifted public speaker,
somebody who wasn't afraid to get on a plane.
Totally, totally.
And get up on a stage and get a bunch of people excited,
and to show up at whatever hour of the day
at a November Project and to get everybody fired up
and now boom, pandemic, all out the window.
Yeah.
You've had to sit
with yourself, that's like an extrovert's worst nightmare.
It's the worst, you love it.
You might have to look in the mirror
and do a little self-inventory.
Yeah, I was laughing at you and Harold talking about this
'cause you guys were like, yeah, it's great.
It's fine.
We don't have to go anywhere
and I was like these guys are idiots.
Yeah, I do not love the social distancing,
I did not love the masks, I don't love it,
I don't love any of this stuff.
And I think early on in the pandemic,
we all had to say, I don't know if you remember this,
but back when we thought it was weeks,
remember it was like seven weeks
or like maybe maybe 14 weeks or whatever,
people would be like, oh, I'm getting tired of this
but you always had to say, but I don't have it that bad,
it was always you had like precursor
or like kind of follow it up with I'm doing fine,
I don't really have anything to complain about
but here's how I'm actually feeling.
And then the longer the pandemic went,
people started hopefully more often,
but I definitely in my community, just sharing,
the drain and the how draining it is.
And I mean, I have my November Project answer
and I have my personal answer,
my personal answer is I realized during COVID
that those little conversations that I thought I was having,
kind of engaging with the postal worker or the barista,
I thought I was like Midwest nice,
polite, I thought I was doing it for them,
once you turned it off, I recognized
that's also how I plug in.
Right, that's your fuel.
Right, and so, you mentioned public speaking
like I don't lead workouts anymore,
I help the organization of November Project
which leads workouts all over the world.
And so, that thrill of stepping up on a Wednesday morning
and then, or even interacting on the community level
with the folks, the people I see on my block,
it was all just brought to nothing
and so, I was surprised at how tough it was.
I thought I could be just optimistic
and just like stay positive.
And then when it got tough, it got draining,
to go...
I'm not surprised.
Yeah.
I mean, I would have duly expected that
you would have a harder go than most people.
Yeah.
And you're not out tunneled.
Who says that?
My sister-in-law, Zoe, said one time when I got back
from a trip, she kind of called me out,
she kind of pulled me aside,
she lived in San Diego and she goes,
man, I think you're having even more fun on the road
than you let on.
And not like shady, but just like,
she was basically referencing
I would come back from these adventures
and I would kind of like play like dad role
or husband role and be like, let's go out to dinner
and let's just kind of be a little bit more domesticated
in kind of indoor voice and that's fine,
because I just had a screaming, wild community driven,
like togetherness, like recess, gym class,
the social structure, all in one,
the fire hose for three days in two cities.
You got it, you had that outlet.
Right.
And so you got fed,
so you can come home and be present and not...
And so like even last year, like the Meeting of the Minds
and November Project Summit were virtual events,
it's like, okay
and you and I have talked about this in the past,
how much can you lean into that Zoom?
Like how much can you, everyone's on mute?
Like how vibey can you get, right?
And I love the challenge, but it's like,
what's an A+ like togetherness vibe,
what does that look and feel like on Zoom?
Yeah.
I mean, it doesn't compare to your worst, lamest,
November Project experience.
Right.
But just also for context, like you don't even like to text
or do phone calls, it's all visual,
it's either FaceTime or leaving a video message or a text.
First of all Rich, they're called short films,
we've gone over this.
They're called short films because they're thoughtful
and maybe artistic.
Send me a short film.
And you've bought in.
Now has that affected,
have you sent or am I your only short film guy?
No, I started doing it more actually
so, there's been, you've impacted me in that regard
and it is better.
It's better.
Yeah.
And then you can get to like the idea of sneaking into,
oh, by the way I wrote you a letter.
You did?
So, I'm a letter writer.
I didn't know whether I was supposed to undo this.
You can open it, I didn't even know it,
oh, it's artwork, I made some artwork.
Right, it's a shark.
Oh my God, you used a typewriter.
There you go, hipster points, hipster points.
Now, and the reason I'm telling you that,
similar to the short film, man, it's like this.
Brogan "Fiji" gram, then you have your phone number
and your address.
You can file that away.
That's the reason that that's the reason that fits
with the short film is that during the pandemic,
we spend so much time on screens,
how can I sneak into Rich's day?
How can I drop a video to Keith Kelly in Utah
and when he needs the vibe and then it fits, right?
'Cause we've all had that person calling you
during the pandemic that you've even caught up with them
for awhile.
Phones have a...
I can't rev another rev,
even for someone I love right now,
I should probably give them an hour, it's been awhile.
And then you miss their call
and it's kind of like (sighs)
and that's for people that you like, so, sneaking in.
So, if you're listening to this and you're a letter writer
or you used to be, get back into it
or send a video to your friend by way of text.
Yeah, because then that way they get to see you,
they hear your vibe,
but there's no implicit obligation
that you have to get back to them right away.
Right.
I like that.
Yeah, so short films, what else vibey?
I think last year was, this is kind of
the more than November Project answer,
but when the NBA canceled, they put their statement out,
we canceled within 24 hours.
Yeah, that was the day...
That was the day.
That was like the Rubicon,
right?
No one can wait around.
That was the day where everything shut down,
we're like, oh, wow, this is like real.
And growing up as a hoops fan,
I liked that the world was waiting,
what's the NBA going to do?
Okay, they're canceled?
Okay, shut it all down.
But we in all 52 cities shut down at the same time
and as a group has never canceled for weather ever,
the only other time we canceled a workout
was for the manhunt,
the Friday after the marathon bombing in Boston in 2013.
And so, it just felt really weird
to be like shut it down,
And we recognize that our leaders
might need a little bit of a breather,
I don't wanna say break 'cause that doesn't really jive,
these folks are just as vibe-y
and we shouldn't have been surprised,
but all these leaders stepped up
and they got the Zoom going
and they started hosting virtual stuff.
And I think it would even seemed a little fun early on,
but as those weeks turned into months and it was just like,
oh, this is just how we do it now,
the workout that you went to in West LA years ago,
you experienced what they kind of come together,
a normal-ish in person November Project experience is,
it's a crowd of people somewhere,
you go in, oftentimes the new people get introduced,
the leaders say what the workout is going to be
and within a few minutes, you're moving
and the block of time could be 20, 30 minutes
but it's usually, the full experience,
you're back in your car, back on your bike within an hour.
And then the reason I'm kind of framing that up is that now
in the Zoom era, these leaders, instead of just saying,
oh you're going to run up the stairs, ready, go,
and then just taking pictures
and doing a couple of flights here and there,
like they are truly fitness experience
hosts 45 minutes nonsense,
it's almost like standup comedy of like...
Yeah, you gotta be (mumbles) Peloton instructor.
Yeah, you're trying to fill it.
And so, the vast majority of our November Project co-leaders
are not fitness professionals
and so, it was a lot of growth and it's pretty draining
and so...
And how long did it go on in the virtual realm?
'Cause you did one this morning,
so, you guys are back at least in some cities.
Some cities are back,
it's going to be a longer road for some than others,
Toulouse, which is one November Project
that we have in France, in Southern France,
is they've got a pretty long road in front of them
before coming back in person.
Here in Minneapolis, we've been back for, I think six weeks,
maybe something like that,
but they're doing it differently.
So, it's not like what you experienced
where there's 100 people,
it's small groups in three locations.
So, now they're covering more ground,
they have three leaders, that's normal.
It's capped, so it's a sign up sheet,
which is on their Instagram and there's a spreadsheet,
you have to sign the waiver...
Which that's really at odds with the whole spirit...
Just show up, right now, it just showed up,
but kind of changing, let's see what we got here.
Your car alarm is going off.
I got it, I should look into the whoop,
the whoop don't make those sounds.
Is your heart rate off the chain right now?
I'm fine, it seems like I'm excited.
No.
Okay.
So, all right, so 20 people per location,
these three leaders, Emily, Eralph and Sarah,
they split up and going back to what we talked about,
like centralized location,
they're able to try things,
like which spreadsheets fill up first
and the extra digital step for such an O.G
like is kinda killing me
'cause it's like that doesn't fit the Just Show Up,
but this is how you have to do it,
masks before, during and after and like a ready set, go plan
for if someone gets COVID, what happens?
What does contact tracing look like?
What do group photos look like?
I mean, you remember with Maggie and Tara, in west LA,
it was like...
I mean, it must have been 150 people there.
Yeah, for sure
and it was like squeeze closer,
okay now, everyone lean on there,
it was like very much like human contact times 100
and now it's like,
so it feels different, but man,
if you've spent 10, 12 months not doing group things,
it feels like so good to be back.
Have you had a situation
where somebody tested positive
and you had to do a contact tracing deal
and figure out how to respond?
Yes.
Wow.
And in those moments, I was very proud of the efficiency,
I know that sounds like a managerial thing to say
because I reacted like...
You're a Human Resources professional...
You know why I reacted, I was like, oh man,
we're in trouble, we are, oh man, we're fucked.
This is going to be a disaster.
And then like the leaders here in the twin cities were like,
no, we reached out to the 10 people
and we followed the list of names from the waivers
and we reached out to them and let them know within a day
the state of Minnesota considered it,
it didn't qualify as a close contact
because it was outside social distancing
with (speaks gibberish),
like they were just on it.
And so, we let them know that they should go get tested
if they're interested and they don't,
it was just like, they kind of did it,
I don't want to say perfectly
but nearly perfectly right away.
I mean, so that's the model we're looking at,
and look, I think with November Project,
for those of us who remember those groups
of a couple of hundred people,
Boston gets four or 500 people, same with Edmonton,
it's like, I think rather than holding on
and being like, I can't wait to get back there
and just be like, no, no, no
because we continue to change,
like we're not going back,
you're not going back to sweaty hugs.
Yeah.
Maybe ever, right?
And so...
Well, I think that is an important idea,
not just in the context of November Project, but broadly,
whether it's, what's going on in this city
and how the world is paying attention to it
or how we're just interacting with each other
and our professional lives.
I think we need to, if we haven't already,
disabuse ourselves of this idea of getting back
to the way it was, we're not going back to the way it was.
We're going back towards something different,
hopefully something better.
Right.
But it feels like every facet of our lives
is sort of being impacted by that idea.
Yeah.
And what that's going
to look like, and it's all up in the air.
Yeah, I mean the really positive,
like let's look at the brighter side, Rich,
side of November Project during the pandemic was
that you could argue it was the easiest time to join.
You can do it from your living room, right?
And so, if you here in the twin cities want to wake up
and do the Zoom with Emily and Rob in New York city,
you just got to get up a little bit earlier.
You can play the time zone game and start with London
at two in the morning on Tuesday night,
I've done workouts with a November project MIRI,
which is in Malaysia, it's this small fishing town
in Malaysia.
I think it's a 2:00 p.m on Tuesday,
you know what I mean?
It's like the idea of like being able to easier,
having an easier route to drop in
on other communities and get to know people,
it's a stretch, especially for someone,
I just finished saying how much I like Interact with...
No, I get it, I mean listen,
it's cool and it's not the same,
I just know this in the context of like 12 step meetings,
it's like a different version of what you're talking about
that gives me sustenance and fuel and a sense of purpose
and direction and grounded-ness and all the like,
and when it all goes to Zoom,
yeah, I do it, but it's not the same
and I do feel my self wanting it to go back
to the way it was.
Right.
And look at some point,
we'll all gather together, the way that we do that
is probably going to be different.
Right.
But the challenge is getting over that refusal
to engage now because you're waiting until that later moment
because you're missing the opportunity in the interim.
Yeah, by the way, how often do you go?
It depends, I mean...
Is that a personal question?
The truth is, no, it's personal, I'm happy to answer it,
I mean, the truth is that my meeting attendance
dropped off dramatically because it's Zoom
and I was like, I just can't do another Zoom call man,
and recently I found my way back to it
and falling in love with it in a different kind of way
because I was just waiting for it to go back
to the way that it was.
And it's the most important aspect of my life
and yet, I couldn't get myself to log on
because I just had Zoom fatigue
and I just didn't want to do it.
Well in that.
Yeah.
To think that add another hour,
looking at screens.
We had a meeting with the Board of Directors
for November Project and of the board members
who was newer to the community said,
who are some of your competitors?
And the joke and the reality is like warm beds
in the morning, 'cause we're a morning only group, right?
And when people are getting up and putting their shoes on
and going have an outdoor experience,
as opposed to opening the lid of a laptop solo
in a quiet apartment, it's such a wildly different thing.
And, yeah, I mean, look...
And I would suspect that you are competing
with the Peloton of the world,
because everyone's at home and trying
to find a workout at home,
you're a free and you're an all comer deal
but without the group congregation aspect of it,
now you're relegated to competing with everybody else
who's doing fitness online.
I want to use this platform
and I'm glad you came here just to let Peloton know
we're going to bring them down.
If you're listening to Peloton,
you're going down, Robyn NYC, you're going down,
Robin, you're going down,
and that's the tough thing like what you said
about the meetings and waiting for them to go back, right?
You mean running into people or connecting with people
over, online, social, whatever and have someone say,
I'm just waiting until they're back,
I'm just not doing Zoom.
Like you almost understand it,
like the way I would speak to someone
on the street years ago, I'd be like, dude, you got this
and I would chop down all their excuses.
And now, we just have to be people,
have to be more gentle to each other,
our leaders in Atlanta are like
we're not going to be pushy recruiters,
if we get five people who want to be there, that's great.
If we get 15 great,
but we're not going to guilt a 16th person
into showing up to a Zoom experience in the morning,
not knowing all that's pushing and pulling them
in their day.
So, that's something
How many cities are you doing it in person now?
I think 15 or 20.
And the reason I give you that kind of hazy answer is
so, it's not even just a lever of Zoom or in person,
there's different challenges.
There's what's called fly buys
where they'll kind of assign different locations
and like kind of a less centralized hosted thing.
And so, but full swing back with a big group,
like pretty much nothing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah
well, we're in this weird in-between zone right now
where we feel like we're emerging out of this situation
but we really haven't quite yet.
Nope.
And we're all impulse to just say, come on,
let's just get on with life.
Right, and I was like, it's funny, like...
And now like Minnesota is having a little bit of a spike
as a result of that.
I mean, California is doing really well right now, but...
Yeah, and then someone said something about variants,
let's also just use all the buzzwords, booster shots,
what else did we say?
Yeah, I mean, just this idea of like spring time
here in the Midwest,
like I have to check myself a little bit and be like,
just because it feels like we should be back,
that means nothing, right?
Have you had any like days in the 70s yet?
Like that first day where it's a blue sky
and it's like 74 degrees out.
In Midwestern, folks are stoked,
just pasty white legs, just like Minnesota, it's wild.
And yeah, like when I left San Diego,
like it was one thing, no one ever talked
about the weather in San Diego, right?
There's nothing to talk about.
And there is this greedy nature of looking forward
to and surviving a winter,
the Nordic ski scene and the fat tire scene,
things that people, ice fishing,
which no, I haven't gotten into yet,
I don't think I'm going to,
but I had a knee surgery this past winter
and I've spent a lot of time on snow shoes,
walking around and talking to those people out there
in their huts.
There's something that comes to life...
I need did talk to people,
I'm going to put snowshoes on.
It's so bad.
I'm so desperate
to (indistinct) to somebody,
I'm going to walk out on this frozen lake
and knock on his hut.
Boy, and I use the same line.
So these are usually men,
usually kind of standoffish at first.
And here's my approach, because I've lived here
for a year and a half.
My approach is, I've done this, I've never admitted this,
I've done this probably 30 times, 30 different ice huts,
Lake Minnetonka, I live kind of near there.
Hello, hi, yeah, is this ice fishing?
I just moved,
yeah, hi, I just moved here from Southern California,
and kind of just like give them the whole story
and then they'll usually show me the whole thing.
This is how we draw the thing, I know how they do it,
I met a guy last week, so, but I keep that going.
So, I'm going to play the new guy card for like,
I'm gonna play the new guy,
I might play it for 10 years.
You would have to pay me a lot of money to do that.
It would never occur to me to do that.
And I thought it was the drinking thing,
I always thought it was like some Homer Simpson,
like Al Bondi, like they're like...
I was gonna ask, like usually,
those guys are a couple pops in.
I thought that, I thought it was like,
mostly about the cooler beers and maybe a radio
and I was so wrong.
These are like sport fisher people, fishermen.
So there, anyway, I was wrong about that,
I was actually looking for somebody be like,
you want a beer?
'Cause I just thought that'd be cool
to have that experience.
Yes I do, are we friends yet?
One of my buddies in San Diego calls me a friend hunter,
he says that I'm always looking for like that.
What does Goldie think about that?
The friend hunter?
Just like the whole vibe.
The general antics.
When you go out in public and she has to contend
with the guy who's literally going to walk up
to every stranger.
I think she liked it when we were falling in love,
I think it's a lot, it's a lot, it's a lot.
I don't do low key really well,
so, it's like...
You're not like on a trajectory towards the destination,
there's a lot of stops along...
Oh yeah, it's.
Getting from A to B...
Yeah, it's kind of like a multi-dimensional kind
of experience of like...
Fluid evolving.
Let's go over there for a while, no reason,
I don't know, but it's the reason that I think
I have these really weird, interesting kind of occurrences
and I know that, I don't know, what's the Larry Bird thing,
you miss all the shots you don't take...
something you don't take it,
so, for me when it comes to people,
it's like I but had this happen,
just this past summer
and it was toward the end of last summer,
I'm going to do this, I'm going to tell this story.
My knee was still kind of something,
my bike was in the shop, it wasn't happening.
So, I ended up rollerblading, okay?
Imagine me, roller blades, I can skate, okay?
Rollerblading through downtown Minneapolis,
now you see what it's like
and in my past rowing life, I got really good
at checking out rowers on the Charles River
'cause I was a coach after I was an athlete.
And I would watch the way men and women would take strokes,
boom, boom, and the body positioning and the shape
and their build and even sitting down,
but that's a tall person that seems like,
oh they could probably relax their upper body,
I was scouting athletes and bodies.
And so, it's never really left me
and then how we fallen into running essentially,
I'm still checking out runners.
So, last summer I was rollerblading
through downtown Minneapolis,
which was a ghost town as it is.
And I saw this guy
who was just such a smooth, smooth runner,
so smooth, like you can put a glass of water
on top of his head kind of thing.
And I admire that 'cause I'm a big, heavy runner, right?
And my first reaction was,
'cause there's like 9 a.m or something,
I was like just after or just before nine
and I'm thinking, I'm kind of like doing the math,
I'm like, so, this guy's running in downtown,
that seems kind of like a touristy thing to do.
He's a really good runner, long dreadlocks, black man,
looked like he was between 20 and 40.
It was like, okay, friend hunter, okay, this is great.
But then I'm like, and I stopped myself, I'm like, okay,
Goldie says I talk to people too much, okay?
And then, I'm not just trying to talk to a black guy, okay?
But I should, but you shouldn't,
don't go just trying to be friends, hang on.
And I'm like, I'm playing all this,
and I'm like, okay, and I kept skating,
I'm just skate past him.
And I was like, oh, I've become someone else.
You've defied your nature.
Yeah.
And I wasn't proud,
and so like a block later, I was like,
and this is all going on in my head,
a block later, I was like, no, that's not who you are.
You don't have a ton of skills,
maybe one of them is approach, maybe that is one.
And this guy's going to think you're an idiot
and he's not gonna connect,
but you don't know unless you try.
So, I pretended that my roller blade was messed up
so, I waited at the crosswalk and this dude rolls up.
You to create all this artifice.
Totally.
'Cause you've already passed them.
You couldn't look back
around that will weird.
Can't look back.
Yeah.
And he's standing there and I go,
hey, look, man, I noticed
that you are an extremely smooth runner.
And I've got a running injury right now,
but if I were running all these buildings would be shaking
and you wouldn't know it.
He got a big laugh, right?
Skate with a guy for a little bit, from Kansas city,
visiting, he's here to work, very kind of just general.
As a Kansas city, we have a November Project there,
they meet at the War Memorial,
on Wednesday mornings, you should go, you're a runner,
you're up in the morning-ish,
started talking, talking whatever,
we started calling each other on social.
And it turns out he's a journalist for the New York Times
and he covers race and culture.
His name's John Elligan, shout out John.
And I think he thinks I'm a maniac.
He's the guy who's been covering
everything's that going on here for the New York Times?
Yeah, he's the guy.
Yeah.
Trinidadian, Trinidadian, I never tried to say that one,
but we got to try it, we got to practice stuff out, Rich,
out in the open, public record, he's Trinidadian.
I probably butchered that one.
Super calm guy, lifetime runner,
obviously he's an incredible writer.
And he, someone from the New York Times recently said
that he's so dedicated to his work,
he pretty much moved to Minneapolis,
which is accurate to that story.
Well, if this is his beat, he's got to be here, right?
And so then, the only other part of the story
where John Elligan and I overlap
and now I think we are friends,
and John, if we're not, just text me
and you can just tell me, I'll shut it down.
But he was in town to do an interview with the mayor
and Jacob Fry hit me up and he said,
hey, look, I've got the New York Times in the morning.
I hadn't talked to this John Elligan guy,
completely out of my mind.
I had the New York Times in the morning,
so, I should probably go with him solo.
And I said, okay, you're the mayor dude, whatever.
And you didn't tell...
I had no idea.
You didn't tell Jacob this story,
he didn't know this story.
Of course not,
that's just kind of a normal story.
Anyway, he meets up with some New York Times guy,
happened to be this guy in the first 20 steps of the run,
John Elligan says to Jacob,
do you know Brogan Graham?
And they both cracked up
and it was like this great experience.
And so, the reason I'm telling that story
is not to celebrity brag on John or Jacob or you
on the Rich Roll podcast, it is a story...
You forgot what Jacob said,
which was I blew off Brogan to get running with you.
Right, totally, totally.
So, the story is this, you got to go in,
you gotta go in, you got to go in.
Yeah.
You got to go in,
especially now living in the Midwest,
being so close to Madison where I'm from,
my brother was in Milwaukee,
like it started to be kind of like,
where did you go to high school kind of vibe, right?
And I've been living in different coasts
for the last 20 years
and so, it's a cool time.
And I think the masks and the social distancing
and the the intensity that we're feeling right now,
to me, it just feels like restrictions and challenges
of like, okay.
Yeah, well, how did you become friends and running buddies
with the mayor?
Yeah, so when I lived in south Boston and San Diego,
a very dear friend of ours,
a very dedicated November Project true runner
who actually got me connected to New Balance
back in the day, Claire Wood,
now lives in Portland, Oregon,
went to high school with Jacob.
And so, when we moved here, she was like
you should connect with this guy.
And I didn't really know,
I mean, I didn't really know anybody.
He's a former pro runner.
Yeah, I mean, he's a 2-16 marathon.
2-16.
He got like fourth at the Pan-Am games
or something like that, competed internationally for the US,
he has to be the fastest, the most accomplished runner
in elected office in the US.
Yeah, and then also just like a another running fun fact,
like a local, the mayor in St. Paul
is also a former pro runner.
Really?
Good sprinter, yeah.
And so, anyway, these twin cities,
Minneapolis and St. Paul, in my experience and growing up
in a big cause town, the capital of Wisconsin in Madison,
going to school in Boston, being around
a lot educated folks, living next to Harvard and MIT,
that whole zone, and then San Diego has got
a lot of great things about it,
it's not exactly like...
Intellectual hop dead?
It's not where Goodwill hunting was filmed in San Diego,
but moving here, in my experience,
it feels like the baseline level of local politics
and activism and understanding of like those worlds,
in my opinion, it's fairly high.
And so, I think Jacob and I hit it off
because we both liked to run in the morning,
I didn't know very many people.
and then when he would talk about work,
I'd be like, I don't love you, man,
but I don't know what the heck you're talking,
I don't care, like I care a little bit,
but like, not really,
and I think he's got a world full of people here
that has got a lot of demands.
But I would suspect that after living here for a while,
you don't really have the latitude did not care,
like you quickly become somebody who cares
and you seem like somebody who does care
so, I mean, not about the intricacies of wonky policymaking,
but just in terms of how local politics
has a very real impact on the people that live here
and what that means because of what's happening here
to the rest of the world.
Like, it's very significant what's going on right now.
Yeah, and I would say that since the last year and a half
of being here, I'm engaged,
I think I understand what's going on on a local level
but the people within reach in my life here,
in the twin cities are kind of more
toward the activism level of what feels like unhappy
no matter what happens, sometimes,
and so, that's hard.
Yeah.
Like I think we should all wake up and do our part
and there's always going to be more work in any topic,
in any part of this...
I can't imagine the pressure
that Jacob Fry feels right now to try to keep things intact,
it's gotta be unbelievable.
Yeah, well, you'll talk to him.
And the extent to which running helps him process
all of it, I would imagine.
Yeah,
I mean, he speaks on running the way a lot of folks
in the November Project community speak
of running where it's like, if you miss your run
and you get that extra 90 minutes of sleep
or an hour of sleep, it doesn't do as much for your day
as had you traded that sleep for the experience, right?
And so, yeah, he runs crazy hours,
I should say his day is a long day that starts early
and yeah, I admire people that are up,
out of bed doing something physical
before they go into whatever their role is in any community.
And so I don't know, it takes a lot of criticism,
a lot of shots from a lot of people,
but like you don't...
There's a lot of vitriol and a lot of,
like it's split, right?
Like a lot of people don't like the guy
and a lot of people are on board with him
and he's at the intersection and kind of the,
he's the sort of vehicle through which a lot of people
can process, whatever they're unhappy with
about how things are going down right now.
Yeah, I mean, and he's a handsome, really fast runner
that if people don't like him,
they find a way to really not liking him,
and he's a white man and he's also,
this is a key piece, not from here.
Right.
Right,
and I think in a lot of cities,
especially for the position of mayor,
that matters a lot.
He's from Texas, where's he from?
He's from Virginia.
Okay.
Well, Claire and he went to,
so yeah, and it's a re election year, so.
Right.
But I live in the burbs,
so, I can't really even vote.
So, good luck, Jacob,
good luck everybody.
Speaking of getting up and getting the run in
so that the rest of your day goes well,
that's something I did today.
I can't say I got up all that early...
Do you want to timestamp it?
I was not going to make...
Given specific standards.
November Project, it is two hours later here.
So, what time specific...
Let me, so...
So, you ran out.
No, I woke up at 8 a.m here, I think.
Right.
Yeah, I woke up at eight,
so, I was like getting up at six.
Totally and there was snow on the ground...
But it's also in the wake of having done a podcast
with Matthew Walker the other day,
who's the sleep expert guy
and he talks about how important eight hours is,
you got to get eight hours no matter what.
So, I've graduated out of that,
like I have to get up at the crack of fuck,
no matter what.
Right.
Vibe, which you're still on board with.
I am.
And as you get, I will tell you this
as your senior.
Right.
As you get older,
that sleep becomes a little bit more elusive,
especially when you travel across time zones
and you're in hotels and stuff like that.
I'm only taking advice from older dads.
Okay.
That's like my new thing.
That's one piece of advice
and we played this out a little bit
because in kind of trying to plan the itinerary
for this trip, you were getting all hopped up
and I was like, I had to throw the rain on that parade
'cause you're like, we're going to do this
and we're going to do that
and I was like, whoa, dude,
I have to make sure that I execute on these podcasts
at the highest level that I'm capable of
and if I overbooked myself, I'm not going to be prepared,
I'm going to be tired,
I can't just be running in a million different directions.
Yeah, you did like a Papa bear, like reply all email,
that was like, it was very un-fun,
you were a downer.
But just so you know, for future like trash talk,
that will come your way, from yours truly,
like that worked, it was a good method.
Right.
And the email was,
I think most of the Catherine's room were on there,
it was like I need to focus on what I came there for,
I was like, oh shit, sorry, dad.
But yeah, in tribute to you coming
in that Smack down of an email.
I was nice in the email.
There you call me in my place and I also,
leading up to this have been getting more sleep
and with the ride to downtown and back,
I've started calling that,
I've been like nicer to myself to be like...
So, you ride your bike in the city every day,
which is 20 miles, you go back and forth, right?
And I'll count that as my workout, right.
So like, instead of having to get up and do something
and then the ride,
I've just been like, okay, Rich is coming,
I'm going to cut back on the beers,
get better sleep and just call my bike ride good enough.
It's still 40 miles of riding,
if you hit that hard, that's pretty good.
Yeah, anyway, if I seem like extra on it today,
it's because I'm getting better sleep.
Right, well, this is what I want.
Yeah.
'Cause this is
for the ages, my friend.
Totally,
this is locked in forever.
But speaking of the the little jog
that I did this morning, I mean running around ...
Yeah, where did you go?
We're right in downtown, I don't really know where I am,
so, I just kind of ran around...
The buildings.
The streets
and the buildings and the bridges and stuff.
Yeah, cool.
It was eerie, like everything is boarded up,
everything is shut down, barely any people out,
you see media trucks, you see a lot of tripods and cameras
and people getting ready to cover what's going on.
Yeah.
You had been sharing pictures of police presence
in like Humvees and stuff like that,
I didn't see that much of that this morning,
but it was still pretty early,
perhaps that happens as we get towards evening.
But it was strange, it was strange to be in a city
that I'm not familiar with,
it's my favorite thing to wake up in a new city
and I don't even look at a map or anything,
I just go outside and run around
and try to get a feel for the vibe.
Right.
But there's like no vibe.
There's no vibe?
Because there's nothing out there
and nothing going on and getting it last night,
we couldn't get any food because there's no delivery
I was like, oh my God, we might not be able to eat.
I love that, I love that,
'cause that was a travel disaster story,
like no food, I didn't eat all day.
Well, I just figured like usually the worst case scenario
is you get room service spaghetti, which we did,
but it was really expensive and not that much food
and I was like, this isn't going to do it man,
we got to find somebody who's going to deliver to us.
And I ordered it through Door Dash,
they charge your credit card and then they cancel on you,
so, like $250 later...
You're on to a thousand...
I thought I had food coming
and then they tell me, no, it's not coming,
but we're still gonna take your money.
I'm going into a mild panic.
The part about the police presence here right now
is frustrating 'cause and I know that this is a can of worms
so, we don't have to get into this,
but like every time I see a Humvee
or a bunch of armed guards with machine guns here
in downtown Minneapolis, I wonder,
I just think about January 6th,
I just think about what that staff looked like
on the steps of the capital.
So, there's that
and then, I want to circle back on something you said
because I told you some jokes last year
that landed pretty well,
which was just about how thoughtful your podcast was.
But I was for the first time
so in my head kind of about everything going on,
that I kind of fell off the Rich Roll podcast,
yeah, I know, but it feels good
to say it on the show, right?
Yeah.
So, but when the cameras,
but not completely, I was still
probably doing an episode a week, okay?
Love John Sally, I love that he always
has to go pick up his daughter, it's like my favorite thing.
Yeah, he keeps having a bail.
I love that.
But in the conversation you had with Knox Robinson,
shout out Knox, you examine something
that you just said just now,
which was this idea of when you get to a new city,
you like to go run around
I am completely the same way, but to the run world,
to the white folks in running,
like if you feel that same way, explore a city on foot,
like it's so unique.
And I never think twice about it
and I've done it all over the world.
Totally.
I've done it in Muslim countries.
Just whatever.
All kinds of crazy places.
Globally just...
I never thought about my safety even once.
Split shorts, should I bring a phone?
Nah.
And so like, again, I try and find points of entry
to see white privilege
and like for the running world,
if you like to explore a city that you don't know on foot,
like, let's look at that,
and so I'm not calling you out, I'm calling all of us,
'cause I completely agree when I travel,
I'm like, oh yeah, what is Baltimore like?
I'll just go trot around.
And so, I think that that's another way of looking at it.
But when you had,
so you were saying when Knox came out to visit,
'cause I want to talk about that,
you spent like a whole week with that guy, right?
Yeah, well I think so.
And he was definitely on the Brogan itinerary.
Oh yeah.
And that was all shared in Technicolor
On Instagram stories.
Yeah, we use the phones.
That's a lot of fun...
We use that pink app quite heavily.
So, I'd reached out to Knox last summer, actually,
I think I'd seen him in the sit down that you had
for the Rich Roll podcast,
which I think you did in Los Angeles,
it was like the black drape thing...
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
when you came...
When you started doing that.
It was like right after that, I think, shortly after that.
And I wanted to amplify a voice of credibility in run
but not just someone that,
and again Knox doesn't speak for black people in running,
but he has his own experience
and he has his own set of identities.
And I also know Knox and like ran into him
at a million events and like he's got a kid
and got a couple of kids now.
And, so I've always liked him
and so, I threw him the invite as we were getting ready
to host the Meeting of the Minds
November Project summit, virtually.
And it was going to be another piece of content and yeah,
he came out like, one thing I did understand,
first of all, he said, yes, right away.
Like he said, Knox Robinson said yes so fast,
I was wondering if there was like a...
Nobody traveled more during the pandemic than that guy.
Totally, I would hit him up with a film and he...
He went to Africa.
He would send one right back,
he'd be like, yeah, I'm in Mexico city,
I live here now.
Right, he was was living down there.
What?
Yeah, so anyway, he said yes so quickly,
and it was a really beautiful conversation
that we were able to share, kind of just catching up
on our timeline of like what the Black Roses was,
what they were doing, when are we seeing Jesse
and how he sees run and taking over spaces
and it was,
we recorded that in my garage and it was great.
I thought it was really great, quality and beautiful
but it really was the time around riding bikes
with the leaves changing, it was falling.
But yeah, I think having Knox here,
going back to what my mom said,
it's like there's folks in New York and Los Angeles,
and there's a lot of America in between,
and to have you here and have Knox come to Minneapolis,
Minnesota, or the Burbs where I live now,
it's like, it was cool, it felt good
and with all that's going on here now,
it's just a reminder that there's a lot of communities
that are going through a lot of hurt,
and I have friends in San Diego
that still don't really know where I live.
I mean, they call it Mindianapolis, Mindianapolis.
Yeah, 'cause if you're not on a coast
and then you're just in some no man's land,
that doesn't count.
So, yeah, those were important times,
but again, that was for a gathering,
that's usually a couple of thousand people
called the November Project Summit,
and just to have a virtual offering
and a couple of live things.
It was just like.
So, a lot has happened since the last time we sat down.
A lot has happened.
You got a kid now.
I got a kid now, I'm a dad.
You are a dad.
I'm a dad.
We've had some good dad conversations.
We have, we have,
and I feel like that's my connection to you and this show,
which is just like, I like people
that are out there grinding,
I like people out there that are athletes
in whatever stage of life.
But if you're a dad, I feel that connection to that,
and so...
You're born to be a dad.
Born to be a dad?
Yeah, you're like a dad, dad.
I'm in it.
Yeah.
A minute, I think, I could have been a better dad
to this baby, the baby thing is kind of
like a lot of standing around.
And now that my kid is three, he turned three in February.
So, let's see, okay.
So, we did podcasts in February, 2017.
My son Lumi was born,
Lumi Graham.
Look at that.
Was born.
When I say you were born to be a dad...
This is who I am..
(indistinct) just listening and you're not watching,
you're wearing a tie dye shirt...
And I tucked in my shirt.
It doesn't it just say Lumi's dad on it,
it's like sewn onto the front of it.
And your shirt, when you're a dad,
you should just start tucking in your shirt too,
that's another thing, get into jogging,
tuck in your shirt, read the paper.
I get the print on Sunday now,
so, I'm drinking coffee reading the paper
with tucked shirt.
Typing letters on like ancient typewriter.
I'm typing letters, I mean, it's...
I like on the here, when you just gave me
your phone number, you did the plus one...
And then in parentheses, it's difficult,
like its the 40s.
So, my shirts tucked in and reading the Sunday Times
and I'm ripping out typewriter stuff.
Yeah, so Lumi, yes, he was born a year after the thing
when we sat down,
I've said this before to friends
and I said it on a couple of other things
but I was traveling so much during that time
that I was I was a little freaked out
that I would not want to be home, if that makes sense?
'Cause you hear sometimes friends of mine that are men
that are dads do that kind of oh brother, oh man,
it's a lot, it's stressful, it sucks or whatever.
Being at home or being on the road?
Being at home.
Right.
And you also hear lots of guys talk about
how stressful it is to be traveling all the time.
And I think one thing you and I share is like,
I love it.
Yeah.
I'm like, I'm not that guy.
Like I love airports, I love, like...
Totally.
Everything, its like,
I get to time travel, how cool is that.
I know where you are right now.
Right, I'm in the Houston airport, I don't exist.
So, I was traveling so much and so thrilled by that
and like my sister-in-law said, I was coming to life
on the road, I was concerned that like,
I'd be one of those dads, like problematic,
like I'd come home and be like, (speaks gibberish),
this sucks.
You're like Jeremy Renner in the grocery store
looking at like detergent and breakfast cereal...
Totally, and just being like, get me out of here.
And I wasn't that way, I still came to life on the road
but like when I was home,
and I think Goldie could say this for sure,
when I was home, I was home.
But the ability to be fully present and grounded at home
is informed by getting fueled up by those experiences
on the road.
Yeah and I think when people talk about exercise
to make your yourself the best self
so that you can be in relationships better,
you can be at your best self at work
and so to keep up yourself, and for me,
that also applies to like the social engagement,
coming to life on the road
and not even really late nights,
not even really like, and nothing too, like R rated,
nothing that fun, like traditionally.
But just still being myself and a dad at home,
being individual, but also being married,
like I think you fall into those things,
like, that's your role, that's all you are.
And so, I was really pumped to come home
to that little baby
and now that he's a toddler, like he actually is fun
instead of like, I think we love our baby,
he's getting bigger, diapers.
Like a year or two of that.
Yeah, they start becoming real people.
Yeah.
And then it gets really fun.
Yeah and so now, almost every day,
Monday through Friday,
I have on my calendar Lumi time,
which is like around five o'clock until he goes to bed,
which is like six, seven, eight, depending on whatever
and it's awesome.
And we go stumble around the woods
or like pretend to go fishing
and like just kind of fumble through stuff,
climb trees, it's like the stuff
and I hate to be this way, but it's like,
we got a big front yard, big backyard,
it's kind of why we moved here, right?
So, and those of you who are on the Instagram
that followed Goldie, she announced yesterday
that we're having a second kid.
I know, it's exciting man.
We're having a daughter, we're having a little girl.
You are.
Which is great, we have enough white dudes,
there's enough white dudes.
You were like thinking there.
Well, what I was thinking,
you know what I was thinking,
you know what I was saying.
What?
I don't know that I know.
Well, I think that the understanding
and the growth in our society, but definitely,
in my household and definitely for me personally
around gender and what matters and identity
and then going to this baby gender reveal kind of vibe
of like, we're having a...
I thought if I was paying attention,
we we're supposed to not even talk about it.
They're like, it seems outdated to pop the balloon
and the pink confetti comes on and we say girl,
and that means dresses...
You definitely don't want fireworks.
Right, so I remember seeing people on social media
being like we're doing the reveal and being like, what?
I didn't know we were still doing that,
so that's my part.
Yeah, I don't know,
I guess it might be a regional thing too,
I don't know, it depends on where you live, I suppose.
Right.
But the progressive notion
is that we no longer do that.
We're not doing that.
Yes.
And so then this is like,
man, all right, tell him the story.
I came home on my bike, my in-laws were visiting,
Jen and Gary were visiting
and I was a little bit late
and I could tell Goldie was agitated.
They we're doing the thing we're doing it
and I was like, well, what are we talking about?
Her mother had talked to the doctor on the phone
so, the only person who knew if you were having a boy
or a girl was Jen and she had gone to the store
and got a big balloon and well, we're doing a gender reveal.
And in that moment, I had to decide like,
be scrooge and ruin Christmas
and like take the energy out of it
and like, we're not doing that
and her mom is like a nice thing for her mom, whatever.
And I even said to Goldie, I was like, are we doing that?
And then I realized like, shut up, shut up,
don't ruin the moment.
But maybe we can, it goes back anti racism,
it's like, maybe I can have a conversation
with Jen and I can ask Goldie,
we're not going to post the pink balloon popping,
that's a bad, we're not doing that,
but maybe we can engage and have these conversations
and then we all kind of win.
I wish we didn't do it,
we did it, and we popped it.
Okay, so then I was kind of scrooge
on the inside and smiling on the outside.
Okay, cool, I didn't stand up for much, okay, great.
And then we sent it to our really good friends in San Diego
who have a boy and a girl.
And they sent us back a video of them watching the reveal
and they were jumping up and down
and screaming and crying and it was like so beautiful.
And I was like, oh, that's awesome, okay.
So, that's just a lot of words, I don't gender reveal.
It's complicated these days.
Right?
Yeah.
So we're having a...
So, go back to the top, we're having a girl.
Congratulations.
Thank you, we're having a baby.
Yeah, it's cool, man.
No, we're still, we're still.
Yeah, I love the videos that you share online
with you Lumi and Goldie, it's beautiful.
Yeah, thank you, we're stoked,
and with a mom named Goldie and a dad named Brogan,
and an older brother named Lumi,
I think we should name this girl, Sarah.
Just go straight up the middle, you mean?
Like Emily?
Just because you need a straight map.
Right.
Like you can't have, everybody can't....
No, totally.
Whack.
Totally...
I mean, let's be clear,
it's not just Lumi, it's Lumi Cobra.
Lumi Cobra Graham.
Where does that come from?
So, when we found out, when we found out we were pregnant,
when we found out Goldie was pregnant, new age stuff,
and this is a dad thing I'll teach you
'cause you're a little bit further down the road,
apps, people have tracking apps, okay?
So, you say like, this is the due date
and then that kind of every week you'll be like,
oh, now it's the size of grape and...
Yeah, I missed all that.
It's cool, but actually it's cool,
but you have to put in a placeholder name.
So, the app will spit out,
it'll say like baby Graham or something.
And Goldie is a yoga instructor
and so one of the poses is called baby Cobra.
It's like, you're laying on your belly,
you kind of lift up whatever.
And I don't know how we plugged that in,
but it's kind of cute, she's still teaching
so, I go to her classes and she'd say,
let's all come into baby Cobra
and we all kind of wink at the wife who was beauty,
it's great.
But the further we got like into her pregnancy,
we're looking into their like, and we're referring
to baby Cobra, like we're talking about it,
oh, I can feel Cobra.
And it was like, we started looking at each other,
we're like, okay, she's Goldie, I'm Brogan,
we're like, are we really doing this?
This is actually going to happen.
We've gone too have gone too far.
And then she's looking at me like, and she's outrageous
with the names.
And so she was like, she's looking at me like
for the voice of reason,
she's looking at me as the voice of reason?
And she's like, I don't think we...
I don't know, what are you?
And I'm like, yeah, I don't know.
I guess this is going to be what it is.
And then we're just like,
what does that do to a person,
send them into the world as Cobra?
The pasty white San Diego.
But you can get away with it as the middle name.
Right, so we hit it.
Yeah.
So, it's kind of like...
If you're coming in hot with Cobra as the first name...
Right.
That's a heavy load.
So now it's kind of a parlor trick
'cause how often does your middle name come up?
What's your middle name?
David.
David, it's so boring,
so is mine, mine's pretty much David,
mine's Christopher.
Same thing.
It's the same thing, that's the same...
They got those names out of the same pot,
does yours have significance?
James Stephen.
Right.
Well, it was my grandfather's name.
Yeah.
My grandmother, so my kids'
great grandmother's maiden name was Rocker,
and I think that's a cool first name.
Yeah.
Anyway, what if I married a Rocker?
Right.
And that woman's name would be Rocker Roll.
Fill in the blank Rocker Roll.
Rocker Roll, take a roll call, yeah.
By the way, I want Adam's job.
You're going to have to come
and do some guest postings spots.
The reason, listening to his stuff...
You're a good hype man.
I would be into it...
I'll give you that.
And the thing is, the reason I really despise that guy is
'cause he does a good job, and I like him.
Adam's very good.
Yeah, I mean, with the for...
He's risen to the occasion, for sure.
And it's been great, but I did,
one of the things that I had in mind when we were thinking
about this tour and these live events
was I wanted to have you involved, and we talked about it
'cause you're like the ultimate hype man,
get out on stage and get everybody excited.
It'd be great and I'm so down to do it,
that was one of the many ideas that we've canceled on.
Adam has job security though.
Yeah, what does he do?
He's my hype man.
Is that his full-time gig?
No, he's a New York Times correspondent.
Got it.
Contributor, he's an author,
he co-wrote Dave Goggins book.
Right, right, right, so...
But he's written his own books
and he's working on a novel, he does lots of stuff.
It's called roll-on when the two of you
just chopping it up, when those episodes come up,
because I want his role so bad, his job so bad,
I press play on those podcasts like this,
like you're angry.
You hate listening?
Yeah, I'm like, this is stupid.
And then I listen to it
and I'm like laughing to stuff, I'm like no.
And I'm like, I'm using the discount codes
and (indistinct)...
There's a lot of work that goes in behind the scenes
to show up, we have this robust outline,
he's reading all kinds of stuff.
We're talking throughout the week
about what we want to talk about.
Homework is involved.
But I'm like this kind of like,
I'm like a field reporter kind of like,
I volunteer my marketing ideas and you said Goggins,
so, I've got to roll this out,
I throw you ideas and like nonsense, like all the time,
you mostly get back to me.
And I remember talking to the phone...
I wouldn't say it mostly.
No, you do, you get back.
Do I?
One time, I threw this idea, we were on the phone,
I think we're actually faced...
I think we might've been on the telephone.
Smartphones still have the feature
where you can just call someone,
we're on the telephone, good old fashioned telephone call
with Rich Roll and I was like, oh man, I was on a bike ride,
you don't remember this.
I was like, I was on a bike ride
and I thought of this funny shit
'cause I was listening to you
and a couple of key words came up,
do you know what there's going?
I think so.
Yeah, and I was like, you got to do Rich Roll bingo
and just like have these bingo boards out there
and then when people hear a key word,
they can play along.
I know so many endurance athletes are doing marathons
and stuff but it was the one time in our friendship
where you were like, flat line,
you were just like, it was (indistinct)
with your silence, you said,
I don't like it like that idea.
Like this drinking game whenever I say some word
that I always say all the time.
Totally.
Yeah.
When I'm in the creative space,
you pay attention to those moments where someone's like,
oh, that's a bad idea,
and you're like, okay, we'll finesse it this way,
but instead of doing that, I just went ahead and created it.
Yeah, I know.
You know it, did you see it?
Well, you started mocking me,
you were mimicking me on Instagram
and you did like so, well, let me preface this
by saying when I was getting ready to go on this trip,
my boys who are now 26 and 24,
who have been living at home since the pandemic,
I'm going to Minneapolis, I'm going to see Brogan
and they're like the Instagram takeover guy?
Yeah.
They we're like, I love that guy.
You would go on Instagram and pretend that you're,
oh my God.
So this is...
You are taking over
and then you would act like...
I would pretend like Rich did the takeover of Miami
and I would speak like very thoughtfully
and unpack a lot of things.
Talking about homework.
So, this is...
and then we can do this,
so this is, and this won't catch on
and I didn't talk to Adam about this.
If people are just listening,
you literally handed me a bingo game chart.
Read what it says from the top...
Rich Roll podcast bingo, how to play,
tune into any episode of the Rich Hall podcast...
Yep, any episode, you can go back
and there's like a thousand of them.
Link for keywords and mark each space,
the cutout piece below,
the first listener with five in a row will win.
Many will play, many will win.
Yeah.
Peace long pause, players.
Now read some of the keywords here.
So, here on the chart, the keywords,
I like how at the bottom two,
you have a little scissor thing to cut out
like your poker chip.
This is interactive.
This is like a lot of work.
This took me 25 minutes of love for the organization.
So, here's what you get on the pink,
on the (indistinct)
Just can you say it again, Rich Roll Bingo,
can you just say it?
Rich Roll Bingo.
It flows, it's nice.
Yeah, all right, go ahead.
John Joseph is right there at the top left.
So, let's go back to the beginning.
So let's go back to the beginning.
Refuel, gut health, endeavor, Goggins.
Yup.
Mindset
Doesn't mean a lot
of winners...
Ultra health, decoding,
.com/rich roll, a lot of that.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that...
Well, 'cause now you're doing those
in the middle of the show, right?
Studio.
Right.
And then right in the middle
you just have the symbol, like the prince.
Yeah, is that upside down?
I couldn't figure how to put that right.
It goes with you, I think he did it right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Authentic spirituality, recovery dually,
precipice's new book.
Yup.
Subscribe, hindsight
and even deeper look, swim run.
Yeah.
Paradigm busting and vegan.
I was going to do the cheese that your wife,
what's Julie's cheese...
It's missing a few here though,
oh, Sri mill, she's missing a few.
Well you can...
Unpack, I thought that was your favorite.
That is my favorite, let's...
Land this plane.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't wait.
So, what you could do is you could knock this all out,
like you could just really Rich Roll it up
in the first 10 minutes.
Like everybody would win in short shrift
and then they get a discount code for 10,000 shorts.
All right, I appreciate the effort.
Thank you.
And I like how it's colorful
and you used all the fonts and everything.
I'm going to keep coming with ideas.
What do we do with this though?
Raise money for charity, man.
Rich Roll Bingo is on,
Rich Roll Bingo is on.
But I'm serious about next time you blow
through Southern California, you got to drop in on a session
with Adam and I, and...
I would love to...
Chime in and participate.
In the Roll On Endeavor.
For his shout out, especially with the Goggins thing
that he did, the four by four by 48,
I was walking on lake Minnetonka, in the frozen whatever,
and I was listening to him talk about running
and then you talk about training,
and it was like this really beautiful thing
where he and I hope this isn't insulting,
I'm meaning it as a compliment,
but he was talking about running
in a way that more people can relate to.
Like, I don't want to call him a couch,
so 5K is way more than that
but it was like he was approaching run
with like, I think he said like 25 miles a week,
like trying to try to get into it.
And you were like, phase two, hang on,
well, how are you?
And you were trying to help him
but it was almost like you guys were too far a little bit.
And I thought it was awesome
'cause you have so many listeners
who are super serious athletes
but also people who move a little.
And I thought it was beautiful.
No, I think Adam is very relatable in that regard,
like he's aspirational and the things that he's trying to do
with his running and his swim run and fitness
and all that kind of stuff.
But I think he does sit in a position
of more of the listeners in terms of like how they think
about these things.
Yeah, and then how did it go?
Did he crush it?
Did he do the thing?
He did it great, yeah.
I rode my bike down and checked on him a couple of times.
Did it get ugly at the end?
He did pretty good, Jason over here
actually did it as well.
So, they were checking in with each other throughout.
Oh, that's awesome, that's awesome.
I was coming off the knee thing,
I was not going to do that,
but I was still stoked for him.
Were you uncomfortable that you couldn't rise
to the occasion?
Absolutely.
Instead snowshoeing out on a lake Minnetonka,
like looking for fishermen to talk to.
It's surprising you haven't started a podcast.
Too much work, man.
That's it?
Anybody who could put together this podcast bingo chart
could probably...
Rich Roll pod, you just got to say the whole thing,
Rich Roll Podcast Bingo.
Okay.
The Goggins thing is crazy and I think...
I will do the four by four by 48,
Goggins has been on your show, now and I'm not joking,
but Goggins has been on your show like four times.
No, no twice.
Okay, he's in the twice club with yours truly.
No, but I am inspired at Goggins,
I liked Goggins called a friend of mine's dad
who was battling cancer.
This was just a few months ago and left him a voicemail.
Wow.
And you know Steve (mumbles)
so, it's his dad and the two, Steven is his dad
read the Goggins book and the whatever
and so, I'm not even a huge Goggins fan
but when I heard his voice,
like in this really matter of fact way
talking to Steve's father about taking this thing head on
and like you got this, I was just like, okay,
I called Steve on the phone
and I was like, well,
you definitely have to do the four by four by 48
and he was like, he only had a few weeks
and he's in great shape
but I don't need to know much more about Goggins
'cause that was like a really well-placed perfect, like...
That's beautiful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And Steve's dad is doing much better.
That's cool.
So Steve, he's the November project leader in Buffalo?
Yeah, yeah and he's like one of the earliest fans
of this podcast and frankly,
he's a friend of mine that I get to know
through November Project.
Yeah, it's cool, it's cool,
he visited us in our house several years ago.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So anyway, he came on in 2017
and they've been doing a great job in Buffalo ever since,
he's also like Mr. Connector in that city,
like everyone knows him, but yeah.
Back to Lumi.
Yes, so in your daddying,
I guess he's probably not old enough to really understand
kind of what's going on in this city
that he lives in it, right?
Do you feel like you,
can you talk to him about all of this stuff yet or not?
So, can you talk to him?
So, I have friends that are most excited
about anti-racist work
through the lens of being parents, right?
And what history classes we took and what things we learned
about the United States and like,
how will that look for this next generation?
And so, I'm very interested in that
and I'll be completely honest,
I haven't begun those conversations,
he has a hard time sitting still and...
He's too young.
He's into he's into coral reefs and things like that
but not too far off, to be honest,
I was speaking to some other dad friends
where especially last summer here,
living in uptown in the very organized, peaceful protests
and some of the riots, like I remember seeing it,
whether it was on TV or just listening,
just out my front window and thinking like,
I gotta be out there, I want to be in the mix with people.
One of the leaders in San Francisco reminded me
this week that there are other ways
that you can have as much or much more impact,
but going back to what we said earlier
about who I am and how I connect and how I participate...
Yeah, I would imagine, you're like,
you need to be right and...
I'm like, honey, I got to go
and she's like, you're not leaving us here, that vibe,
and so that was a real like push-pull
for like the fatherhood thing of like...
What is your responsibility?
Right.
Where is your time best spent?
Yeah but I did and I still do take him out
on the bike seat, little bike seat on the back,
dad life man, tuck in the shirt, kid goes in the back
and we would go do some peaceful marches
and protests and things and I would talk
about how these are mommy and daddy's friends
and everyone's wearing black and Black Lives Matter
and we've been to the George Floyd Memorial,
now it's called George Floyd Square,
I went once by myself and then the next day,
I took just Lumi, I didn't let Goldie know,
but then the three of us went the next day,
which has its own kind of set of opinions
which is just kind of this tourist vibe
of like going to the place
where this unarmed black man was killed.
Yeah, which is something we're going to do
after this podcast, right?
And it is a loaded thing,
like you don't want to be a looky loo,
like how do you approach that
with the correct level of like respect and appreciation?
It's not about your Instagram moment.
Yeah, and this was a conversation that came up
with Knox when he visited.
I said to him and I said to you, which is like,
if we don't go, I understand from a personal point of view,
I think it's important.
Any steps closer you can take to the reality I encourage,
and I know I'll get blow back for just even saying that
and for me to my kid there and my wife
and we took pictures again, supercharged with privileged
but like George Floyd and our move to Minneapolis
and I don't know how much longer we'll be here.
He could, you know go to college at the U,
this could be where we are forever, but if we aren't,
or if we are, his first history lesson that he lives through
that he knows is George Floyd,
and we went to the place where he was murdered
in broad daylight.
And look, if there's some judgment there
and not only do I understand it, but I see it,
and at the same time, I think keeping kids in cocoons
and not telling these stories is absolutely wrong.
Yeah, 100%.
So then it's that corner on Chicago Ave,
is 0.4 from where we lived.
I ride my bike on every corner of the city,
so yeah, we're going to go.
One of the things that we've talked about
a couple of times on FaceTime with respect to being a dad
is the challenge of trying to figure out
what that means in 2021, right?
You're no longer Don Draper
who's going out and doing whatever
as long as you're paying for everything.
You can't just be the super sensitive guy,
you're expected to be strong, but also emotionally available
and vulnerable at just the right time.
You have to be the good listener,
but you also have to be the person who knows
how to erect the boundaries
while making a living that's going to support
the people that you share a home with.
And it can be overwhelming and confusing
to know what that roadmap looks like for you.
Yeah, I think it's a stress
that it's also not cool to complain about,
if there's not much of a space for men to be like,
wow, this is a lot.
I think you're supposed to, I got this,
you're supposed to be on,
so, yeah it's complicated.
I mean being...
Part of that is yes
and part of that is part of the problem.
For sure.
You know what I mean?
Like, just being like I'm just going to buckle down
and solve the problem.
Yeah.
Isn't necessarily how you solve the problem.
Right, and then what stereotypes do we continue supporting
and like what do we still think is the husband,
that role thing?
For example, around the house,
I didn't really want to necessarily move to the Burbs,
we did and now we've got this house,
and the house has like a water heater,
what the hell is a water like furnace?
I don't know, I'm just saying things now,
I'm just saying things now, a sink,
I knew that one before, carpet, wood floors, things.
So, okay, a lawn, okay.
Now I've got my shirts tucked in,
It says Lumi's dad, I'm pushing a lawnmower,
it's all coming to life.
But I've gotten some shade from the moments
where Goldie is like, hey, can you fill in the blank,
build the dresser or hang the lights or like the thing.
I can't do any of that.
I can't do that stuff.
And then I grew up in a house
where we were kind of always doing projects and things,
but like, so it always,
especially in my new like suburban house life,
it feels like fail to like call like a real guy
with a tool belt
and he owns the saw to come saw my stuff, right?
If the washing machine breaks or whatever.
Totally and so like,
as if we buy a house and the dad
that knows how to fix a dryer, same day,
it's like, what are you talking about?
So, I think pushing back is...
So, it would be like the stereotype
and I tell Goldie this
when she's like, are you pissed?
And I'm like, yeah.
She's like, well, explain yourself.
I'm like, I don't know,
that's like a dad thing.
I should be able to replace the ceiling fan
or something and a lot of my home is...
Pissed meaning disappointed in yourself
because you feel like you can't live up to that.
That's the role.
That stereotype.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
and then I throw it back on her,
and I was like, that would be like me saying
you're cooking sucks, like you can't cook.
And then she's like, well, I can't,
and I'm like, yeah, shit.
Yeah, you're a pretty good cook,
okay, maybe I should learn how to fix the ceiling fan.
These stereotypes, like what our roles are,
and so, I mean, going back to just the one-on-one time
with your kid, putting your phone down
and like how you talk to kids,
like the generations before us,
and also some of us had parents
that didn't have all those conversations,
that weren't so open.
And I really admire the parents
who have a relationship with their kids
where for most of their childhood for sure,
maybe up until they're teenagers
are coming to their parents and ask some questions, right?
Yeah.
And if you don't have that communication open,
who's that on, right?
Yeah.
Mother or father or whatever,
like I think that's on the parent.
So those are some good goals that fall outside of the roles
and the stereotypes.
It's just like, I think I can do that.
I do that with a lot of my friends
lot of my guy friends, and so...
One of the things I've learned
as I continue to try to figure out this parenting thing,
I've said this before, but the older boys are my stepsons,
I had a hand in helping navigate them into young men
but I wasn't their dad, but I was around all the time.
So, I feel like on some level I participated in that.
Do they know their dad?
Yeah and he's since passed away and their dad was great,
and he was a great dad.
So, I was always very respectful and cautious,
not to overstep that boundary.
With these next two, who are my children,
it's been a lot harder.
And when I thought I had a grip on what parenting was,
I'm continually challenged and brought to my knees
because I would have never imagined.
And one of the things that I've learned
to get back to my original point is no matter what you do,
like that pendulum swings back and hits you in the ass,
so, when you're like, I'm going to be the open dad
who tells them all this stuff, they reached a certain age
and they're like, why are you telling me all this?
That you might get angry that like...
You're an idiot.
You should just be like,
I just need to know that you've got it under control.
Right.
But if you were that guy,
then there'd be like why didn't you tell me,
it's rigged in a way that you're not going to win.
Right, right.
You're in in this like weird mouse labyrinth
that only leads to like damage control.
Right, right, right.
And learning how to come to terms with that
and be okay with that has led to a lot of pain
but also some hilarious conversations with my wife.
And is that for the two younger kids,
was that always that feeling
or was that mostly teenagers?
No, this is all kind of coming out as they teenage,
they reach a level of sentience
and look, kids will try to identify
by either becoming more like you,
like, they're gonna to take your lead
and look up to you and be like, I want to be like dad
or I want to be like mom
or they try to craft their identity
in opposition to him...
Right, right, right.
So we're in that right now
where it's like, whatever we're doing,
that's definitely the wrong way to do things
and they have to figure it out for themselves
and as a parent, you're like, well,
let's give them that opportunity that path
'cause you want them to push their boundaries
and figure out like what works for them
and what doesn't, like that self exploration,
that differentiation, that trying to figure out
who they are in the world as they get older.
But at some point, you got to put the guard rails up, right?
But where do those go?
Like, it's so...
It's stressing me out Rich,
it's stressing me out, let's go back to fishing.
And I said to you, like, when you said like,
we're going to have another baby,
I'm like, good, well, in 15 years from now,
you'll be good (indistinct)
Totally, totally.
No, there was definitely like,
you controlled some of this story,
You control the pacing on this,
which was like, you said some very sweet things
over the years, we were like,
oh, I remember watching my kids in the sink and time flies.
And when I see you with Lumi, I miss that,
it's like I'm not in that stage anymore.
And it's so precious in just being 100% present for that.
Like it's such a cool time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then like it cracks me up like,
for whoever's listening to this,
imagine if Rich Roll was your dad, how wild is that?
And then you talk about the pendulum swinging,
so like what?
So, like they're eating beef, nachos,
and hey think your shit is just terrible.
Basically.
So what are the funny things that...
Julie and I will then go, when we're talking about it,
she'll be like, what will this joke be like?
There's all these people out in the world,
they would love for us to be their parents.
Totally, totally.
'Cause you know, this thing like younger people do,
it's like internet speak in YouTube comments,
they'll just say, dad,
like dad, like, oh like you're the mentor
that I need in my life to have this,
so, I get those comments on...
like dad, dad, dad, dad.
And I was like, but my kid they're like...
Bone head.
No bueno.
Yeah, totally, totally nothing.
But I mean, when you were a teenager,
what kind of teenager were you?
I was super good at (mumbles).
Were you?
Yeah, I was a grinder.
I mean, I got into, I mean, when I was around 14,
is when I started to get serious about swimming.
So, it was all about swimming and then it became all
about school and I was very judgmental of anybody
who was like out having fun and messing around
'cause I was like very directed.
Yeah.
But I was also socially awkward.
Right.
I was not a good looking kid.
Yeah, you were socially distancing back in...
you did that...
I was an O.G in social distancing.
Yeah, you started this whole thing.
I had weird looking glasses, bad haircut...
And you still do so.
I know, right?
No, I mean like that's the thing I'm fearful of,
is I was a really bad teenager,
like going back to the Harvard statement
and say to him comment in the commentary about race,
it's like we would bend and break every rule,
like the story,
and I only have one of the other siblings,
an older brother, is two years older,
and he was a little closer to your end,
he didn't break as many rules,
but like, I was this big when I was 15 and a half years old.
Wow, that's a lot of energy.
And so my folks were divorced
and so I spent time in both houses
but like my mother had her hands full with us.
And so, I just think about how I use my creativity
and my energy back then
and I had a lot of it, social connections,
I had a lot of like traditional popularity
and I used all of that to like fuck around.
And so, how did you slowly emerge out of that?
How did I slowly emerge out of that?
It was a couple decisions, towards the end of high school,
in what felt like really last chance opportunities.
And going back to the commentary on race,
like this world wouldn't have been as K-pop patient or kind
to some of the things I did and got away with,
if I weren't a loud, charismatic, white kid,
captain of the basketball team, kind of like that guy,
I got into rowing at the end of high school,
I barely graduated high school, but I got into rowing
'cause people said you'd be pretty good at it
and there's college opportunity maybe, but whatever.
And I got into acting in high school.
Other than that...
Yeah, we talked about that on the first podcast,
that's the less known...
Yeah, that's that the...
B plot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You could have gone this whole acting trajectory.
Maybe I'm too big, I'm too big.
But anyway, so I picked up,
I got in to acting in my senior high school,
I got into rowing, and these were two like cult worlds
on their own, and they both grew very quickly,
and they both were taking me away from that idea
of I was kind of overdrive.
And so then college became a thing
and then Boston became a thing.
And then I was surrounded with a bunch
of definitely not straight laced,
but like goal-driven rower type,
kind of preppy, kind of hardcore, like jock dudes,
College division one, college athletes,
and from there, you kind of like...
(indistinct)
100%, those guys are out there.
And so yeah, so that was it,
but we still played in the margins
and Saturday Nights still came and like so,
when it comes to being a dad now,
it's like, I would be freaked out
if he saw my playbook, you know what I mean?
When it comes to like ruckus.
So, anyway, we'll see to be continued.
Yeah but the universe, God, whatever you want to call it,
rigs it in a certain way that you'll get your buttons pushed
and you'll get challenged in ways that you can't foresee.
Totally.
You know what I mean.
And it's like, it puts right in front of you whatever it is
that you need to look at within yourself.
100% and I love that,
I mean, the challenge of being a dad, right?
That's the hardest thing I've done
and I have a friend who's about to become a dad
in like couple months.
It is also, there's no second place,
there's not even like, there's no podium,
it's like the first, second and third
best thing I've ever done, right?
So, it's so cool, right?
Yeah.
And it's the hardest, it's so hard,
you just give up everything,
I'm not complaining.
This should roll out on Father's Day actually,
you could bank it.
When is Father's Day?
It's like June or something.
Maybe it will, we'll see.
And you've got to get this once a year.
Well, if we're going to do that,
then you gotta take it out,
you gotta take it out on a positive Father's Day.
Yeah, in positive...
Typewritten letter to the the erstwhile fathers to be.
Fathers to be,
friends at St. John in North county.
I tell new dads this all the time,
it's not like anything,
it's not like going to grad school and late nights,
it's not like being tired or sleeplessness,
it's not like, it's not there isn't,
there isn't a comparison.
And you also don't love anything like this,
it's not like your favorite team home game
against the Yankees.
It's not like the best experience,
and so, I don't speak this way that often,
but I really believe in it.
And so, when that comes planned or otherwise
and you're going to be a dad, it's like,
don't try and understand it, just live it,
live it, live right through it,
and keep your eyes wide open,
and keep your phone far away from you.
And ironically, still take a lot of pictures somehow
and drink a lot of water.
Say, please, and thank you.
Hydration.
I actually don't care a lot about the rules
in our house, like we're gonna raise Lumi this way
but I drill the please and thank you thing, my dad did.
So, my kid is like this wacky loud mouth
but he says please and thank you a lot, I'm fine,
that's good.
So, just pick your battles, I would say
that's an important one.
Like how you think you're going to shape your kid,
good luck, it probably won't go that way,
but if there are things that are worth
picking your battles for and stick by it,
the please and thank you thing, that's big,
and then don't think you're going to figure it out.
I used to surf with a guy who told me with all confidence,
he was three or four weeks away from becoming a dad.
He said, yeah we decided we're not really going
to do a stroller.
We're just going, I don't know,
I'll probably just get like a backpack or something
and like, Coachella's coming up,
so, we'll probably still,
I mean definitely still going
and I was like...
And you've done a good job of this biting your tongue,
but like, what are you talking about?
Like keeping your own opinion on the side of,
there's times when you know it's not about you.
Let me know how that goes.
Cool, yeah, no stroller dope,
like, meanwhile, I didn't ever think I was,
I have three strollers,
like, you know what I mean?
So, like this idea of like controlling the future,
like you know.
So, to my dads out there, you will never get the credit
and there's so much more to do.
And being a positive male role model,
I think is an important thing.
It's the best.
And guide your kid to a life with anti-racist work in it
'cause I think that that's the place
where we can make the biggest change,
the quickest change, even though it seems like years
and years, decades and decades,
like I think those are the changes we'll see quickest, so...
Beautiful, man.
There's only one thing that I would add to that,
which is in those moments where you're being tested,
which are going to be more frequent than you expect
and you feel like I gotta get outta here
'cause I gotta do that thing
or I'm gonna call that guy.
It's just like, remember, this passes so quickly,
I've been doing this for a long time,
and when I see the videos of you with Lumi,
I'm like, man, it doesn't seem like it was that long ago.
And then I look at my kids and they're so much older
and you forget how quickly it passes
and just to be able to be present
and appreciate what's actually transpiring,
it's great to say, put the phone away
but like, how present are you?
We're going to climb a tree and just forget
about what your agenda is and just be,
'cause it's not about like,
I'm gonna create the ultimate day
and we're going to go to the amusement park,
it's not about that.
Right.
It's just like,
just be present with the kids
and give that child your full attention.
And that's the most powerful and greatest gifts
that you can do, you can give
That's really well said, it's not the stuff,
it's not the right hamper,
it's not the right wall color, it's not the crib,
it's just like, if you can do those things,
you could be playing a bucket of sand,
it doesn't matter.
So, that's that man,
I really connect with that.
So, once again, Rich Roll, it's been an honor my man.
I love you brother.
Love you too.
Yeah.
I'm really proud of you
for coming to the twin cities during this...
Why?
You gave me a reason to go on an adventure too,
and I'm really happy to be here
and I feel excited about what I'm going to learn
over the next a couple of days.
Yeah, yeah.
It's it's an important time, before people start talking
about what we're doing with our hours in this time,
during this time and the sensitivity around it,
let's agree that it's an important time.
And if you're a storyteller
and if people listen to you and you have influence
and a platform, which is undeniable, then you belong here,
you need to be here, so.
Thanks man, thanks for bringing me out.
Peace, plants.
Namaste.